هذا الحوت اثار تكهنات بانه جاسوس مدرب من
البحريه الروسيه عندما ظهر عام 2019
ملفوفا بحزام من صنع الانسان في النرويج
واليوم عاد الحوت بلوجا ليثير الريبه من
جديد بظهوره قباله الساحل السويدي تقارير
افادت بان الحوت رصد لاول مره في اقصى
شمال النرويج وامضى اكثر من ثلاث سنوات
يتحرك ببطء اسفل الساحل النرويجي قبل ان
يسرع من خطوته فجاه في الاشهر الاخيره
يبلغ النصف الثاني من السواحل النرويجيه
الى ان ظهر مؤخرا قباله سواحل السويد
علماء في الاحياء البحريه قالوا انهم لا
يعرفون سبب تحرك الحوت بهذه السرعه في
الوقت الحالي خصوصا انه يتحرك بسرعه كبيره
بعيدا عن بيئته الطبيعيه وهو ماثر الشكوك
مجددا حوله فعندما ظهر الحوت للمره الاولى
ازال عنه العلماء بالنرويج حزاما مزودا
بقاعده مناسبه لكاميرا للاسط الحركه مع
عباره
على المشابك البلاستيكيه فيما لم تصدر
موسكو ابدا اي رد فعل الرسمي على التكهنات
النرويجيه لانه يمكن ان يكون جاسوسا روسيا